okay so this is Shh with a bikini babe
that's right she just goes into our room
is just like you know so very fitting
and yeah this is an episode I thought we
do this hole would just people would
kill us sister I can't quite do that
ah but those signs are very funny from
the last dug yes so okay so this is
episode they just decide not to talk
right they don't have a reason they just
decide the dog wakes up and Jake just
has a sign and that says he's not gonna
talk and Finn just happens that one as
well so yeah they just haven't decided
on that day so then they have a contest
for who can go the longest without
talking and sure enough
sure enough BMO gets confused and thinks
that Finn and Jake have been taken over
and they can't make any more signs
because that was part of the deal that
you only had 30 seconds to make all
these signs Finn clearly didn't make
enough
I don't know how Jake or anybody can
make that about in 30 seconds but oh
well so I remember he's got he could
make multiple arms that's freaking
lighting write them all up to say it
something like that so many are
bizarrely specific but maybe he just
made enough of the enough of the cards
so BMO runs into into the crack in the
house and they're trying to get her out
and they come across when I super just
like others silent-film ish creations
and that's our kingdom I you come on I
saw that spider I'm like that doesn't
look like anything they've ever drawn
you know it was funny but you know I'm
like that does look like anything that
they would draw there's some sort of
writer or animator and there's something
you know just saying life in the wall is
a drag I'm curious what the story by
then after the James Baxter one now like
what's the story behind everything
guys a story I'm sure and be the spider
what it was was the gloves on the hands
yeah because that is the like classic
animation style I mean all of it was the
classic style but just as gloves on the
hands in the holes yeah like it was so
like that and the mice when the mice
stood up and everything else like my god
I swear I've seen these in like just a
classic silent once
it looks like Mouse to me the Nazi oh
yeah I don't think that was intentional
I never actually thought of that but I
don't know how it would connect anything
aside from comics don't have sound I be
it so I don't know how but oh and yeah
so they go and they try to bring her out
and she's right it's that cuz she found
a bunch of bikini babes and they want to
dance
and finally they work their way in beemo
says they're imposters and they coming
in and they fight and then Jake finally
gives in and talks and then they
revealed to be Moe that it was perfect
game but she doesn't care they just want
to dance and that's our episode the
party monster shows that the party
monster shows up that's right at the
very dirty wolf the party wolf yeah I
think well whatever he's called but yeah
he shows up at the end he's a party god
he's rockin - he's having fun so I get
kind of like the last one it's you know
I think for a while we sort of got these
really heavy episodes that you're really
heavy episodes that's kind of nice too
like it's not just hey here's a light
one that will go back to the heavy ones
it's like no yours here's the light ones
for a bit and like they're good light
ones like they're they're really funny
and unexpected in goofy I love it when
they fly to the top of the house and not
even like they don't grow wings or
anything they just go like this so yeah
I thought was really funny I thought it
was you know pretty clever I like that
they don't talk throughout the whole
thing
anyone with dyslexia can't read is
really gonna eat this episode but so I
hate it but no I I thought was really
fun I thought was very
funny how about you jewelry yeah I know
feelings gonna be an answer okay
you know all the people that don't like
Jory are like this deficit we Chewie and
Hoshi do is look sexy did not talk
that's what I love it
cough cough that that kept talking
j-money uh-huh good I like this episode
it was a lot of fun I did love the old
the nod to the older animation styles
and just the whole silent era even to
the point where one of the notes they
wrote to beemo is really cute now you
know we love you we're the real one boba
we love you like they're actually stand
out which is really cute and sweet but
then like classic cartoon-style they
just running grab two axes and start
hacking away at the wall it had to be a
shining reference when Jake sticks its
head it have a little bit of a jack yeah
partially you know it was one of those
ones just like because you really don't
see that very often anymore just people
grandly grabbing axes and hacking away
the rain is very more like Tom and Jerry
asked if anything you know I like I
really liked that I really enjoyed it I
like when a whole episode for the most
part where the main characters don't
talk and it's actually able to work you
know you have beam of course going
what's going on here
and you have the bikini babes being like
be mild like I said we want to dance but
like Finn and Jake is just Nicene them
go you know or Jake huling I'm saying
don't touch my signs and then of course
you know there's a little bit later
thing going through the signs and
everything Alan he's like wait did you
did--we did you go through my signs he
was like wow and it's like flopping out
though what makes you think who went oh
I love that end of those great I really
like how
I can't just serve in their character
they stay so dedicated to this even
those causing so much trouble and it's
scaring their little friend you know out
of her wits and they can't get her eyes
like all of this can be you know solved
if they just speak to her but they want
and they won't lose the thing is that
you'll be really disappointed it's like
nothing else it's yeah only for the
bragging rights and that just makes it
so much funnier to me I think if there
really was something on the line it
actually would be a little less funny
yeah it's the fact they're only doing it
for the pride I also loved the fight
scene fight scene just imagine like take
your favorite movie James Bond desperado
you know any of these movies where
there's like some fight scene and cut
out all of their sounds not the punching
that the music but anytime they go oh
right nothing like that
just how silly it would sound well yeah
like him away the hey oh it stopped like
when when they tackle Jake and
everything they're rolling his face is
just our anything like it's just
consistently silent and it just seems
more silly and I'm just imagining
watching like a boxing match where
there's no sound coming from either of
the boxers it's just and they're just
like that's kind of like if Buster keep
doing a little bit of that like do you
say like how come you don't smile and
you don't react and I review ever had a
reason it's just like oh I wonder if
that maybe could also be another nod
considering silent area baby boy yeah
Pete names Ellen air okay very well be
by the way you kids need to go watch
some more Buster Keaton Buster Keaton is
awesome like everyone's always like Oh
Chaplin and Jeff was great don't get me
wrong it's also you know the great
master but I think buster keep a little
more when I loved about Buster Keaton
and I'll stop after this be enough
subject is when you know he's on a train
that's gonna fall off of a bridge he's
actually on a train that's going to
actually fall off of an actual bridge
it's not weird special effects when that
building falls as it really has to go
through that one window that's an actual
building falling and it you know I miss
those days
now I'm going to go off with my bikini
babe well I'm gonna go off with my water
and one of the bikini babes flip-flops